[Musik]
ich bin bei 0 0,0 0 habe keine einnahmen
und werde von meinen kindern finanziert
das ist mal so wenig geld haben damit
habe ich nicht
jetzt ist er in rente zugesichert von
700 euro es ist eine katastrophe in
deutschland im gange sie wird nur nicht
gesehen armut ist stunden
armut ist stumm und sie versteckt sich
oft wo man sie am wenigsten vermutet bei
menschen die selbstständig harz arbeiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vera hesse ist in magdeburg zu hause
doch einen besuch in der city muss sich
die 71-jährige genau überlegen
das straßenbahn ticket für zwei euro 10
ist zu teuer für schmales budget
sie kann nicht wie viele andere ihre
rente in vollen zügen genießen
dabei ist vera hesse geschäftsfrau im
stadtzentrum gewesen
viele magdeburger kennen sie als
inhaberin eines lotto ladens wenn man
selbstständig ist ist man ja auch bemüht
diesen laden am leben zu halten
und ich hatte ja auch in der nähe ein
ganz besonderes publikum einen guten
kunst an aber das war zu wenig es war in
den 90er jahren als wäre hesse hier den
laden eröffnete die viele andere wurde
sie nach der wende arbeitslos doch
anstatt abzuwarten hatte sie den mut
eine eigene existenz aufzubauen weil es
ins kalte wasser gesprungen gut und ich
habe überlebt ich bin nicht irgendwie
encaustic aber unter welchen umständen
muss man heute sagen dass ich keine
anständige rentenversicherung aufbauen
könnte
701 euro bekommt wäre heiße nach einem
berufsleben ausgezahlt in dem sie
täglich 13 stunden und mehr im laden
stand
doch mit ihrem geschäft waren auch wo
ausgaben verbunden ladenmiete kredite
dagegen standen nur sehr geringe gewinne
aber es war menschen also dass ich nur
300 euro hatte die rentenversicherung
die war ja noch weit weg da es gedacht
irgendwie schaffst du das schon aber ich
habe es nicht geschafft
trotz ihrer finanziellen not gelegt wäre
hesse wert auf gute kleidung im laden
des deutschen roten kreuzes ist sie
stammkundin
hier findet sie günstige gebrauchte ware
denken wir dass meine größe aber ich
muss nicht alles haben
ich finde es immer schön mir das
anzugucken mit einmal wieder gern würde
wäre hesse wieder mal richtig shoppen
gehen
es ist so ist dass jede frau gerne macht
aber es ist ja hier ein kleiner ersatz
[Musik]
wer möchte sich gefallen auch wenn sie
kaum geld hat man soll ihr nicht ansehen
dass altersarmut zu ihrer jetzigen
lebensrealität gehört unsere kundschaft
es meist also was so bis zum rentenalter
traurig aber wahr so das macht am 5 bei
einem leben unter der armutsgrenze sind
fünf euro nicht wenig
[Musik]
stefan rausch aus weißenfels steckt noch
mitten im berufsleben auch er hat sich
selbständig gemacht
sein geschäftsmodell ist ein lincoln
town car hat einen v8 motor und ist 860
hindern
ein party mobil mit dem sich steffen
rausch als chauffeur vermietet
wie viel man genau für so einen
schlitten hinblättern muss das will er
nicht verraten
[Musik]
sag mal wenn man von 50.000 aufwärts
geht bekommt man schon ein gutes auto
einen teil vom startkapital hatte sich
der ehemalige lkw-fahrer angespart
den rest kredit bekam er direkt von
händlern ein risikogeschäft für dass der
wagen ohne probleme laufen muss das auto
ist steffens zweite berufliche chance
vor acht jahren hatte er sich bei einem
unfall zwei rückenwirbel gebrochen
die große frage für ihn
und da kam mir der gedanke wenn ich
schon längere zeit drängt für romy
tragen habe mit der limousine weil das
wörter beinhalten ich würde sitzen
dürfen
ich hätte mit menschen zu tun die
weißenfelser volleyballerinnen feiern
ihren pokal in der regionalliga
sie wollen spaß und party steffen rausch
bietet all das auch alkoholfreien sekt
eine stunde für 180 euro das gibt die
vereinskasse noch her sonst wird er eher
hochzeiten oder junggesellenabschiede
erzählt steffen meine größte angst war
im prinzip weißenfels ist keine
großstadt wie berlin oder hamburg
ob es überhaupt bedarf daran gibt dass
das freut sich meine dienste mein
service genutzt wird
mittlerweile hat fast räder im
burgenlandkreis die stretchlimousine
schon gesehen und den chauffeur um
seinen schlitten beneidet doch der
schöne schein trügt auch solche sätze
hört nur wahrscheinlich nur von
angestellten also ich darf im prinzip
nicht krank werden weil die
krankenversicherungsbeiträge sind sehr
sehr hoch liegen um die 400 euro
monatlich 400 euro hat man aber keinen
tag kranken der dabei also wenn ich
jetzt wirklich krank wäre bekomme ich
von derzeit 0 sind von den nöten des
schiffes allem die gäste nichts
sie solle es auch nicht immerhin steht
so ein auto ganz klar für ein
sorgenfreies leben
doch der nächste inspektionstermin
wartet schon mit der stretchlimousine
muss er in die spezialwerkstatt die
hohen laufenden kosten machen es für
steffen schwer jetzt auch noch an seine
eigene alterssicherung zu denken
wie bei allen selbständigen zahlt auch
bei ihm keiner einen arbeitgeberanteil
für die renten- oder krankenversicherung
in der werkstatt dann eine schlechte
nachricht einen drastischen preisanstieg
gekriegt fast 500 euro hier wurden im
rang elf das bleibt letztendlich an mir
am unternehmen hängen weil ich kann
jetzt nicht dass alles auf meine
fahrgäste umlegen
stattdessen hofft steffen auf die eine
oder andere
mehr mit ende vierzig hat petra kern in
ihrem brandenburgischen zu hause eine
nähstube eröffnet ein lang gehegter
traum den sie sich verwirklicht hat als
sie vor acht jahren arbeitslos wurde
damals musste die gelernte
facharbeiterin für fern sprechtechnik
wald zur arbeit pendeln
als ihr telekom standort schloss und sie
gekündigt wurde hat sie die chance
ergriffen und sich mit ihrem hobby und
einer nähmaschine selbstständig gemacht
die erste die hat damals gab es die
ich-ag förderung vom staat eine kräftige
finanzspritze mit der sich arbeitslose
eine neue existenz aufbauen sollten
petra kern bekam geld um sich die nötige
technik anschaffen zu können wenn die
erste zeit halt nicht offen stand auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt stellt und taschen
und kissen verkauft damit sollte mich
auch kennenlernen
in einem dorf wie geht's fast ohne
laufkundschaft dafür inmitten schöner
umgebung ist eine mail stube ein
besonderes risiko familie und freunde
waren anfangs skeptisch ob so eine
geschäftsidee überhaupt aufgeht
nicht ganz zu unrecht denn der laden
läuft zwar aber auf sparflamme zu ihrem
festen kundenstamm gehört eine baby
moden händlerin petras sachen dürfen
nicht viel teurer sein als die
massenware aus fernost sonst würde sie
ihre kunden verlieren
also im moment sehr wenig im moment so
war ja gesagt meine co komme auf 600
euro
[Applaus]
kommen wieder andere zeiten ist ja
schlimmer die leute sehen zwar dass ich
viel arbeit habe aber die sehen ja nicht
dass ich nicht viel nehmen kann
petra steht vor der frage rente oder
krankenversicherung für beides reicht es
nicht
sie hat sich für die krankenkasse
entschieden und zart 480 euro jeden
monat zu manchen zeiten bleibt daher
kaum etwas für sie übrig dann könnte ich
mich höchstens noch familien versichern
wir ohne eine möglichkeit aber da müsste
ich den weniger arbeiten und noch
weniger verdienen als selbständige merkt
petra wie schwer es ist ohne
arbeitgeberanteil jeden monat die
krankenversicherungsbeiträge zu stemmen
dass es viele menschen sind die das
nicht schaffen erfahren wir in bad
segeberg einer kleinstadt in schleswig
holstein
hier gibt es eine arztpraxis für
menschen ohne krankenversicherung
und die hat immer mehr patienten immer
mittwochs öffnet das ehepaar denker die
praxis ohne grenzen
hinter dieser tür entscheidet nicht die
versichertenkarte auf ein mensch
medizinisch behandelt wird
der 80-jährige allgemeinarzt kümmert
sich mit seiner frau um jene patienten
deren versicherung keinen arztbesuch
mehr bezahlt er macht das aus
überzeugung nicht für geld aber warum so
eine einrichtung in einem land in dem
seit jahren die allgemeine
krankenversicherungspflicht besteht
offenbar wurde das gesetz gemacht ohne
an die selbständigen zu denken
so kommt das eben zustande dass jetzt
inzwischen in der bundesrepublik so
genannte nicht zahl ergibt sind zwar der
krankenkasse können aber nicht zahlen
und wenn man jetzt mal die zahlen die
ich anschaut dann sind es bei den
gesetzlichen kassen 450.000 nicht zahlen
und bei den privaten kassen sind es von
der 16.000 also zusammen fast eine halbe
million die ihre beiträge nicht zahlen
kann
uwe denker konnte diesen zustand nicht
länger ertragen und gründete vor neun
jahren die praxis ohne grenzen
sie läuft nur durch die hilfe von
privaten spendern
alles hier ist durch spenden finanziert
damit menschen für die keine
krankenkasse zahlt doch noch versorgt
werden können was zu meinem schritten
die auftauchte war der mittelstand der
deutschen mittelstand als ich ja 80
prozent der fälle die ja unsere klientel
bildung sowie dieter schmitz für die
kamera hat er aussehen und namen
geändert
die geschäfte des 68-jährigen immobilien
händlers laufen schlecht er hat schulden
bei der privaten krankenversicherung für
die ermittler war eine 860 euro
monatlich bezahlen müsste das ist viel
mehr als eine schmale rente und die
gelegentlichen aufträge hergeben
schmöckwitz aber klagt über luftnot die
er dringend behandeln lassen muss so
lange schon hat er mit dem gang zum arzt
gewartet dr uwe denker betreibt die
einzige praxis dieser art in der
umgebung vor einer wie schmöckwitz
unentgeltlich behandelt wird aus spenden
werden medikamente behandlungen durch
fachärzte und manchmal auch ubs bezahlt
im deutschen gesundheitssystem die große
ausnahme
seine patienten nehmen weite fahrten auf
sich so wie jürgen huber auch er möchte
nicht erkannt werden vor wenigen jahren
noch millionär und bauunternehmer jetzt
ist er bei 0 und fährt in einem
geparkten auto zum armen arzt nach bad
segeberg darauf zu verzichten
ich habe keine aktien
ich hatte immobilien immobilien die mir
einen absolut sorgenfreies leben im
alter sichern sollten dieses ziel habe
ich auch erreicht aber da bin ich 2011
erkrankt
und habe meinen
meine schirm in hände der mitarbeiter
gelegt den händen
der prokurist
als einzel gesellschafter und voll
haffter musste er für alle vorgänge im
unternehmen geradestehen
im zuge der insolvenz wurde ihm sein
komplettes privatvermögen gepfändet und
sogar für die grundsicherung wurde er
gesperrt wobei es schuldner bei seiner
krankenversicherung
wir hatten uns unfähig behandelt wird
das damen gezeigt wird das dann von der
versicherung wenn ich meine
weitere schulen erstmal möglichen haben
für einen mittellosen ex unternehmer wie
huber gibt es kein soziales netz
erst hat er auf risiko gespielt jetzt
fällt er überall durch bis auf diesen
arzt der ihn behandelt
heute muss ich auf alles ein was kommt
diesem arzt erzählt huber verdanke er
sein leben eine tiefsitzende
ohrenentzündung hat ihn bereits
einseitig taub werden lassen
unbehandelt wäre es zu einer
lebensbedrohlichen blutvergiftung
bekommen der überweisungsschein macht
sofort klar dass es sich um einen
unversicherten patienten handelt
mittlerweile haben die partner
krankenhäuser erkannt dass für doktor
denkers patienten tatsächlich gezahlt
wird und wir erklären hier uns
einverstanden
die kosten zu übernehmen wenn es sich um
stationäre maßnahmen handelt ist es ja
immer ein höherer satz der anfällt dann
lassen wir es vor einen
kostenvoranschlag geben bevor wir selber
in die pleite gehen was doktor denker
immer wieder erlebt ist dass die
patienten oft viel zu lange warten die
meisten wissen gar nicht dass es solche
ärzte gibt es geht um leben und tod in
manchen fällen wirklich wahr daran
bricht diese eine ganz aufgeregt ich
habe seit 14 tagen klaren blutungen ist
es wohl gefährlich und dann haben wir
kollegen niedergelassene kollegen geht
die sofort eine rechnungskopie machen
und gucken und da haben wir jetzt
kürzlich zweifel gehabt war ein
fortgeschrittener darmkrebs
die ursache dieser blutung die mussten
dann sofort operiert werden
das haben wir dann veranlasst und haben
die und operationskosten übernommen
zum teil in einem fall haben wir diesen
patienten leider nicht retten können
weil das zu spät gekommen ist der krebs
hatte schon gestreut und der ist an
seinen metastasen tochtergeschwülste
geflossen ist er gestorben
das ist natürlich auch sehr aircraft
fasste er
und wir haben ja den vorteil dass wir
beide abends darüber reden können
dieter bohnenkamp ist 81 jahre alt wenn
er sich nicht krumm macht hat er nichts
er bekommt keine rente ausgezahlt
bohnenkamp lebt von den kartoffeln die
er selber anbauen und an die kunden in
bielefeld und umgebung verkauft das geht
in seinem alter eigentlich nicht mehr
aber sein kumpel rolf auch schon 80
hilft ihm unentgeltlich auf seine rente
verzichtet er nicht freiwillig
bohnenkamp ist vielmehr stinksauer dass
er als selbständiger kleinbauer bisher
keine bekommt obwohl er jahrzehntelang
pflicht zahler in der
landwirtschaftlichen alterskasse war er
soll erst seinen hof aufgeben bevor er
rente bekommt so regelt es die
sogenannte hofabgabeklausel die die
gerichte schon seit jahren beschäftigt
ich habe eingezahlt und wenn ich über 40
ja das ist eine enteignung enteignung
auch gentleman hat
über jahrzehnte fühlt er sich vom staat
betrogen und wir haben sie jetzt schon
bin ich dort alle zusammen rechnen fast
um 200.000 beschießen
und wenn ich als kleinbauer mit wenigen
hektar parkfläche leidet bohnenkamp
besonders unter der hofabgabeklausel die
die rentenzahlung bisher an eine
bedingung knüpft hof abgeben oder man
bekommt nichts
die bestimmung stammt noch aus den 50er
jahren
früher sollte dadurch sichergestellt
werden dass die jungbauern zum zuge
kommen und ihre eltern sich aufs
altenteil begeben
das ehepaar bohnenkamp aber hat gar
keine kinder an die es den hof vererben
könnte die anderen ein außenstehender
gar nicht vorstellen
ihre zwölf milchkühe haben die beiden
schon aufgegeben übrig ist noch eine
mutter kuh mit kalb die beide versorgt
werden müssen
im hohen alter müssen die bohnen kamps
reduzieren auch wenn sie auf ihre
einkünfte angewiesen sind
[Musik]
man könnte sagen ich verbrachte jetzt
aber diese 450 euro
die reichen am ende auf mitteln bedacht
ist ja nicht nur das ihr alles
bestreiten können also das wird auch
nicht ganz einfach für den kleinbauern
ist es undenkbar dem ärger den er seit
jahrzehnten bewirtschaftet ganz in
fremde hände zu geben
nur damit ihr 450 euro rente kassieren
darf er will seinen boden nicht hergeben
wissen wenn man das 40 oder 50 jahre alt
und noch länger wenn ich seine
verbindung wohl kamps geschichte zeigt
auch wie bedroht bäuerlicher
kleinbetriebe sind weil sie sich für
viele einfach nicht mehr rentieren
schneiderin petra kern weiß dass sie mit
ihrer nähstube auch keine großen sprünge
machen kann und so hat sie ihre
ansprüche drastisch heruntergeschraubt
wie gesagt
klamotten nicht über nicht über zehn
euro
das auto wenn sie traurig
ganz allein auf sich gestellt wurde es
trotzdem nicht reichen
aber da ist ja noch petras mann er ist
angestellter eines bootsverleihs und der
zeit hat er mehr arbeiten macht der
beruf ihren spaß
die änderungsschneiderei eine
alternative zum jetzigen zustand sehen
beide nicht für petra ist ein zurück in
ihr früheres leben als berufspendler in
ausgeschlossen obwohl er jetzt für sie
mit zahlt bestärkte seine frau in ihrer
selbständigkeit damals abgelaufen und
heizung ist kaputt gespielt und wollte
eigentlich in magdeburg und wieder
schichtdienst sondern waren die
verbindungen so katastrophal sagt eine
frau
hier war ein bisschen weniger und in
köpenick von natur ist bescheiden
futterstelle mit tomate recht und so die
gehen sehr selten essen mietwohnung wenn
nicht gar denke das war jetzt sieben
oder acht 100 euro oder man 900 euro
noch miete bezahlen müssten jeden monat
also das von euch schaffen wir sind
eigentlich froh und glücklich das war
mit der abfindung von der telekom die
restschulden vom haus begleichen konnten
die idee von der ich ag die vor jahren
noch so viele in die selbständigkeit
gelockt hat sie funktioniert bei petra
nur weil ihre umstände ist gerade so
ermöglichen dass abbezahlte haus ihr
mann der die belastung mit trägt sie hat
auf ihr angestellten gehalt verzichtet
und dafür
gewonnen in erster linie macht muss
arbeit spaß machen wenn ich jetzt
versuche ich jetzt zur arbeit ging nicht
so ganz mir keinen spaß macht auch
steffen liebt seinen job und vor allem
die stretchlimousine die alle blicke
magisch anzieht
aber nach zwei jahren musste er sich von
dem gedanken verabschieden damit allein
über die runden zu kommen sein fuhrpark
musste erweitert werden
[Musik]
der geleaste kleinbus verursacht zwar
auch wieder erhebliche kosten dafür
bringen die fahrten regelmäßigere
aufträge ein
jetzt kann er auch krankenfahrten oder
flughafentransfers übernehmen
wichtig ist dass muss ich leisten kann
dass man alle ausgaben die mit zwei
fahrzeugen service wartung alles drum
und dran die ganze versicherung die
ganzen steuern und die
krankenkassenbeiträge auch bezahlen kann
wenn steffen rausch in ein paar jahren
in rente geht wird er in etwa so viel
bekommen wie vera hesse 700 euro
monatlich
damit könnte sie eigentlich
grundsicherung beantragen und sich vom
staat unterstützen lassen
doch die sache ist verzwickt wäre hesse
bewohnt das haus ihres verstorbenen
lebensgefährten muss dafür immer noch
raten abzahlen
gebaut wurde es als sicherheit um im
alter unabhängig von miete zu sein
ihr partner aber starb unerwartet die
beiden waren nicht verheiratet
eine witwenrente erhält sie deshalb
nicht und weil die wohnfläche des hauses
zu groß ist bekommt sie auch da keine
unterstützung vom amt
es war nichts geregelt es gab kein
testament und wenn das nicht unser
beider kind gewesen wäre
die jetzt erst mal auf ihr erbteil
verzichtet hat dann hätte ich hier
wirklich ganz alt aussehen
ja da es aber unser gemeinsames kind war
von der sache her hat sie jetzt erst mal
auf ihr erbteil verzichtet und ich darf
jetzt hier erstmal wohnen denn der jetzt
nicht so plötzlich sturm wäre wäre ich
jetzt nicht in dieser misslichen lage
denn unsere ziele und unsere wünsche
alles verwirklichen können auch mit
meiner kleinen rente die pläne fürs
alter waren mit einem mal dahin
jetzt aber hat wäre eine neue
perspektive gefunden
mit 71 jahren beginnt sie einen mini job
in einer nahegelegenen ferienanlage für
die rezeption sucht die stadt gommern
eine aushilfe den umgang mit kunden hat
wäre ja längst verinnerlicht
[Musik]
ja das wäre jetzt noch frei da könnte
ich sie eintragen
ich habe mich gefreut dass ich diesen
job erhalten habe es war ganz happy dass
man noch praktisch am leben teilnehmen
kann dass man vieles wird von den leuten
vieles erfährt und nicht irgendwo ins
abseits gestellt wird dieter bohn kampf
weiß nicht wie lange er noch kartoffeln
selbst ernten kann
doch er gibt die hoffnung auf seine
rente nicht kampflos auf er ist mitglied
im bäuerlichen verein gegen die
hofabgabeklausel zusammen mit seinen
vereinskollegen hat er vor jahren schon
klage beim bundesverfassungsgericht
eingereicht
die chancen stehen nicht schlecht dass
bohnenkamp noch in diesem leben eine
rente bekommen wird die hoffnung da habe
ich noch nicht aufgegeben
und ich hoffe dass der verein das nur
durch sie vier monate später als die
kartoffeln kurz vor der ernte stehen
erreicht die bohnenkamp eine nachricht
die sie nicht mehr erwartet hatten
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
hofabgabeklausel in ihrer jetzigen form
abgeschafft
sie ist in härtefällen zu denen auch
familie bohnenkamp gehört als
verfassungswidrig eingestuft worden
jetzt endlich steht ihnen rente zu
da dachte ich höher nicht richtig ist
kann doch nicht wahr sein es kann ja so
unerwartet da hatten wir gar nicht
mitgerechnet
aber man kann ja froh darüber sein und
wir sehen auch fröhlich darüber kommt
das zu spät für sie oder kommt reichlich
spät wenn man 17 jahre auf rente wartet
verstehende ich werde jetzt im dezember
82 und dass man da zehn jahre durch alle
instanzen klagen muss nur um etwa recht
zu bekommen
bisher haben die kartoffeln das ehepaar
am leben gehalten und nun mit seiner
kleinen rente könnte die ta bohnenkamp
nun endlich in ruhestand gehen doch bis
das geld auf seinem konto ist kann es
sich immer noch hinziehen
der bundestag muss erst noch abstimmen
hunderttausende selbstständige in
deutschland sind auf dem weg in die
altersarmut
einzelkämpfer ohne gewerkschaft ohne
politische lobby
in bad segeberg geht die sprechstunde
von doktor denker zu ende
in drei nachmittagsstunden hat er mit
seinem team fast 20 nicht versicherte
patienten versorgt ich finde dass meine
patienten schuldig möglich lange
durchzuhalten
er ist einer der wenigen die in not
geratenen selbständigen helfen das
problem wird dadurch nicht kleiner
der tropfen sind schätzungen zufolge
weit über eine million einzelunternehmer
die im alter von armut bedroht sein
werden